Stephen Amell, who plays Green Arrow.
(cheers)
And this is a show I watch with,
this is a show I watch with my children,
and so I know this show well.
He has said that he would like to do a crossover
onto your show.
Is that something that
(cheers)
Is that something that,
is that something that would want?
I'm not sure,
I have a show.
I don't want just random people crossing over into my show.
(laughter)
I have standards.
I want to approve.
It's like a private club.
I want to lift a rope,
let some in,
and then like,
I'm not sure,
you know, let the Green Arrow in.
Smash, I'm not sure.
You know.
How is it with you guys?
It would be odd.
Tonight on Law and Order,
Arrow.
(laughter)
There have been a lot of,
Stephen's a big guy.
You're a large man yourself.
Yes, yes, very large.
Very large, powerful man.
(laughter)
(applause)
But I think he'd want some apple boxes and stuff
to stand on.
So I, you know,
it might never happen.
(laughter)
He was on here last year.
Was he really?
Yeah, he's gonna be very bitter that you said that.
He's all over the place.